let's get right to the mailbag the last
mail bag before the 2022 midterms you
can email info at davidpackman.com
sometimes we'll highlight a YouTube
comment or a Twitter message or Facebook
message it really could be anything but
it's mostly email and the email address
is info davidpackman.com let's start
today with a message from Fred no this
is the wrong one that's for later here
is the one I wanted to start with
um David Dear Mr Pacman they say I was
attempting to listen on YouTube to the
fetterman Oz debate however your
constant comments and biased
interjections and opinions are extremely
troubling are they really troubling I
should be careful are you wanting to
convince your listeners to follow your
to follow your partisan views not sure
how you can be a leader of a show in
this capacity and expect to be
successful as a reporter you should be
more balanced and especially not give
your comments this is another right
winger
who doesn't have a clue what's going on
I am not a reporter this is a commentary
show this show can only be successful if
I give my opinions now am I trying to
convince people whatever I'm just giving
my opinions it's not troubling that an
opinion person gives opinions and in
fact it's not about expect to be
successful we've got nearly 2 million
subscribers across all of our platforms
actually more like 2.3 2.2 million
across all of our platforms so there are
people who are Furious when I give my
opinion
but that's what the show is and again
it's that lack of media literacy there
is no news show here this is an opinion
show it's an opinion podcast where I
give my opinion I got another email
about the debate coverage and we've been
getting a lot of these because what
happens is
people look for the debate and sometimes
when you type in you know Oz fetterman
debate
our live stream can come up in the first
few results on YouTube and so people who
have no clue about our show will just
click over to it and then they stumble
across me and here I am making comments
how dare I and so people get confused
and they write in and they prefer me to
just sit there silently not saying
anything uh Joe S who
um misspelled his own name
um after listening and watching you on
sidescreen it is very well seen that you
are a demo rat
I believe what this and I believe this
is Joseph
and what Joseph is trying to say is that
after watching me
on the side of the screen alongside the
debate
it became obvious to him that I am a
Democrat now I I know I'm correcting six
or seven different things there to come
up with that interpretation but I feel
like it's probably accurate I am not a
Democrat
and if you want someone who just says
nothing during the debates there are
endless other free streams that you can
find
um one more and this isn't actually
interesting and productive comment about
the debates twitchell says why is it
after a debate where the Democrat
destroys the Republican nothing changes
with polling but if a Democrat doesn't
do well the polls tip towards the
Republican it would seem swing voters
would be the reason but why are
Democrats held to a higher standard this
is absolutely the case and I know that
there are so many right-wingers who will
reject the notion that Democrats hold
candidates to a higher standard than
Republicans it is undeniably true in
every way let's talk through it Donald
Trump could never have been the
Democratic nominee
Democrats would not have accepted an
obvious con man grifter from the
business world who isn't even
particularly good at business but he was
just given a great head start with a
small loan of a million dollars and much
more help with his debt
Democrats never would have accepted
Trump as a nominee because their
standards are higher I'm not a Democrat
but I'm just telling you that that's the
reality the only electorate that would
be so low information and bamboozle-able
that Trump could trick them into
nominating him is the Republican party
because their standards are
significantly lower their standards are
do you claim to be against abortion even
when you're obviously not and Trump did
that do you claim to be religious even
when you're obviously not Trump did it
okay can you attack the right people to
make this way a Mexican rapist and all
this stuff Trump did those things the
standards are way lower
I have to tell you it's similar to a
fault even with like the sexual assault
stuff where Republicans will often
defend their own when they are accused
of sexual assault and misconduct
endlessly whereas if anything Democrats
are too quick to condemn remember the Al
Franken situation what Al Frank the
tasteless joke that Al Franken
participated in was absolutely in poor
taste but immediate demands for Al
Franken to resign which he did Democrats
arguably went too far because their
standards are so much higher than those
of Republicans so that's why the debates
matter in the way that twitchell is
saying astute observation Alan wrote In
this depresses me okay I I this really
depresses me Alan wrote in and said you
say you want subscribers
you say it's free there is no way to
subscribe without paying what kind of
scam are you running oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
as bad yeah listen
as I've said before
it is free to subscribe to our YouTube
channel
we have
over a million and a half YouTube
subscribers as much as it would be
amazing to have a million and a half
paid subscribers we don't okay it is
free to subscribe on YouTube
it is free to subscribe on YouTube you
just hit subscribe it's free I've said
subscribe to the podcast
it is free to subscribe to the podcast
we produce it every day every weekday
and it is free it's on iTunes Spotify
etc etc
the one thing that you pay for is to
become a website member yes you do pay
for that but folks I'm not scamming
anybody
it's really free to subscribe on YouTube
it is really free to subscribe to the
podcast
free to like us on Facebook to follow on
Twitch all those things are free but to
become a website member you do pay all
right please please please let's be
clear
I can't tell whether this email is
serious but it seemed like it was
as I mentioned last week we are working
on a white paper
with techniques for how to talk about
politics with people in your family or
co-workers whatever the term white paper
is a typical well-known term
I got an email from someone saying my
opinion but I would never call a
document a white paper it sounds very
kkk-ish I do love your show besides this
mistake I hope I hope yes I'm
deliberately using a racist term white
paper folks I don't know if this is
serious a white paper is a completely
established and well-known term it's an
informational document that a company
uses to highlight something to highlight
research about an issue or to highlight
a product or a service or a market
opportunity or whatever it's it's a
completely
benign banal term it's it's a white
paper I don't know if this viewer
genuinely thinks that it might be a
racist term
I I just got to move on folks I can't I
can't even deal with it okay it's it's
just a white paper Raymond wrote in
about my interview with former
Scientologist Mike rinder now Raymond is
a Scientologist it might not Shock you
to hear
that Raymond isn't happy with my Mike
rinder interview
Raymond wrote in David I watch your
channel for info on recent political
events but your recent interview with
Mike rinder is one-sided you have
someone who's trying to make money on
his experiences with Scientology I don't
see you trying to get to the other side
of the coin and interview an executive
from Scientology or better yet why don't
you pay a visit to a church of
Scientology so listen
um
no Scientology executives are going to
come on the show
first of all and secondly visit a church
come on dude give me a break at this
point I started to think maybe this is a
Scientologist seems to me Mike has a
problem with the management of the
church and instead of straightening out
his disagreement but air his differences
on your program and write a book to make
money yes that sentence makes no sense
but I'm reading it as written I gave you
more credit than maybe you deserve if
you don't give both sides the same
platform I have been a Scientologist for
43 years there it is and has changed my
life and gave me the tools to deal with
life successfully
um I've researched all of those tools
they're all a scam I hate to tell you
Ray
um ray goes on to say currently and for
about 15 years we don't always agree
with the upper management of the church
but to go to the media and take your
disagreements is irresponsible so David
I challenge you go find out on your own
either visit a church find out yourself
or read a book and see for yourself I
dare you LOL sincerely Ray I've read
I've read five books about scientology
I've interviewed 10 scientologists I've
seen 10 documentaries about scientology
have I visited a church no
would the sanitized experience I would
get if I was even allowed to visit a
church really tell me anything about
scientology no
but I understand
scientologists don't like interviews
critical of Scientology that question
the cult
Fred wrote in and said David I've got to
say for this to be a progressive show
I have been shocked that you have not
covered the Arkansas governor debate
where Sarah Huckabee Sanders is going
against an MIT PhD Democrat Chris Jones
who is the epitome of form over
substance and Pac-Man show ideals in
many ways their debate was today and it
will re-air tonight so listen I I hate
to kind of like end on a negative note
here
we can't cover every debate
that race is not even close the Arkansas
gubernatorial debate AR Governor polling
RCP it's it's like crazy
um yet Sarah Huckabee Sanders is winning
by double digits okay it's it's I get it
Chris Jones is an interesting candidate
we streamed like 15 debates mostly close
races races that could end up making a
difference in the balance we just can't
do everything we can't do everything and
that race isn't close would I love to be
able to cover more sure
but we've got to pick and choose so I'm
sorry Fred but it it is not an
indication of any kind of our
Progressive stature that we were not
able to cover that debate all right info
davidpackman.com
send in your thoughts for the mailbag we
have a great bonus show coming up for
you today which you can instantly access
by signing up at joinpakman.com